[Applaudissements]
comme beaucoup de monde au début de ma
carrière en sortant de l'école
j'ai embrassé directement les codes du
modèle économique classique culture du
marketing vendre toujours plus de
produits et de services pour gagner plus
d'argent
je ne le regrette pas ça va plutôt bien
réussi mais un moment sur cette
trajectoire j'ai perdu le sens et je me
suis dit il faut faire autrement
si tu veux pouvoir construire des
solutions plus durables pour nos
organisations et nos territoires
le culte du profit pour le profit n'est
pas une fatalité
ensemble avec certes beaucoup de courage
on peut décider de changer les choses
pourquoi changer de modèle économique et
bien parce que le modèle économique
actuel celui que nous connaissons
s'essouffle il est même en fin de vie
pour un certain nombre de nos métiers il
convient de se projeter et d'inventer de
nouveaux modèles alors un jour j'ai
basculé
j'ai dit non à l'un des plus importants
clients
petit retour en arrière dans mon
entreprise on vend des chaudières de
père en fils notre raison d'être c'est
de vendre de plus en plus de chaudières
et ça se passe plutôt bien
nous avons une très bonne expertise
technique sur le sujet et nos clients
sont satisfaits
nous vendons des produits plus ou moins
plus ou moins fiables et plus ou moins
performant mais un jour le monde a
changé
de plus en plus de nos clients venez
nous voir avec des devis réalisés sur
internet et en disant je veux celle-là
moins cher un peu le monde qui nous a
été décrit par mariam juste avant le pic
de la stupidité quand même à ce moment
là en tout cas en tout cas c'était notre
réalité et si nous voulions gardiez les
clients eh bien il fallait que nous nous
battions sur les prix et notre expertise
elle était juste pouvoir discuter de la
couleur voulez vous une bleue pour le
mettre dans la cuisine ou une rouge pour
la mettre dans la case et pour garder
nos clients eh bien nous devions
demander plus à nos parties
prenantes toujours plus de pression sur
nos collaborateurs plus de productivité
bien évidemment de meilleurs prix à nos
fournisseurs plus de pression également
et tout le monde se retrouvait dans un
monde beaucoup plus tendue qui n'était
pas viable
alors revenons à cette réunion ce client
ce grand client essaye de nous emmener
dans le schéma classique et là je dis
non
on va pas faire ce que vous voulez et
c'est à ce moment là que je ressens une
des premières grandes impressions du
changement c'est une douleur absolument
incroyable sur mon tibia droit c'est mon
directeur commercial juste à côté qui a
fait un balancement de pied pensant que
j'ai disjoncter complètement pour me
faire revenir dans le droit chemin
c'est ça le changement mais j'ai résisté
et j'ai dit non on va pas faire comme
vous dites
le client a dit chiche il est resté un
peu suicidaire de ma part et si notre
raison d'être devenait garantir la santé
dans les logements voire dans les
bâtiments en général si au lieu de
vendre des chaudières nous construisions
avec le client une solution globale
visant à lui garantir le confort et la
santé sur la durée alors ce qui est
magnifique c'est que dans cette solution
il ya non seulement la chaudière que
nous maîtrisons mais il y à aussi la
performance énergétique
il y a aussi le financement pourquoi pas
il ya aussi le combustible et il y à
aussi la formation et l'éducation des
usagers et donc il y a plusieurs
bénéficié à cette solution vous l'avez
compris l'entreprise bien évidemment qui
pérennise ses relations avec les clients
les fidélise dans la durée les usagers
qui ont une garantie de confort et qui
font des économies et une fille nés et
qui élèvent leur expertise d'usagé
et puis le territoire parce qu'on
pérennise nos emplois on entre notre
entreprise sur ce territoire et on a une
meilleure maîtrise de l'énergie
il y à un ingrédient qui m'est apparu
fondamental pour que ce la construction
de ce type de solution réussisse ses
lacs
opération la coopération ce n'est pas la
collaboration la collaboration c'est
travailler ensemble pour atteindre un
objectif bien défini la coopération pour
moi c'est en plus tenir compte des
faiblesses des fragilités des problèmes
de l'autre pour construire une solution
bien plus performante au service du bien
commun et dans la durée
vous l'avez vu sur l'exemple de 1000
chaudière si le client n'était pas
rester s'il était parti eh bien ça
aurait été encore une preuve que il
fallait rester dans le modèle économique
classique baisser les prix etc etc etc
là il est resté et donc nous avons pu
construire en coopération
une vraie solution performante il ya
bien un autre domaine dans lequel la
disruption de modèles amène beaucoup de
performances de bien-être et de sérénité
c'est l'énergie nous maîtrisons
l'énergie même temps elle est fiable
l etat elle est là en quantité elle et
pas cher malgré ce qu'on peut en dire
et donc nous l'utilisons au quotidien il
n'y a pas de raison de se poser de
questions en parlant question j'aimerais
vous imposer une qui dans cette salle à
quitter les tarifs réglementés voir
quitter les fournisseurs historiques
pour l'électricité le gaz et bien vous
ne devriez pas plus que 15% à lever la
main c'est ça la transition énergétique
c'est ça le changement
si vous voulez des résultats différents
il faut changer de méthode
la vraie folie c'est d'attendre des
résultats différents
avec les mêmes méthodes mais seuls les
bébés mouillé aime le changement comme
vous m'avez pas l'air d'être des bébés
mouiller je vous propose d'expérimenter
quelque chose l'énergie sur un
territoire c'est un capital au même
titre que le capital foncier que le
capital immobilier que le capital humain
que nous constituons tous c'est un
véritable capital mais qu'avec une
caractéristique c'est qu'il est
immatériel il n'est pas révélée alors ce
que je vous propose c'est que tous
ensemble nous révélions ce capital
immatériel
pour le transformer en performance
globale qu'est ce que la performance
globale performances économiques
performance sociale créant du lien grâce
à l'énergie la performance sociétale et
la performance environnementale en
pleine conscience
alors comment faire ça bien moi je suis
un créateur d'entreprise
alors je me suis dit je vais créer une
entreprise mais une entreprise
particulière ancré sur son territoire
une société collaborative d'intérêt
collectif qui va nous permettre ensemble
de créer l'écosystème pour transformer
ce capital énergie en performance
globale or comment on va faire on va
travailler sur les achats l'énergie on
va révolutionner des achats d'énergie
on va travailler sur tout ce qui est
l'entretien du bâtiment bien évidemment
mais aussi la data et on va travailler
sur nos propres comportements en termes
d'énergie et là il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire
prenons deux exemples les achats
d'énergie et bien si vous étiez venus ce
soir avec vos factures j'aurais pu
repartir avec et revenir vous voir dans
dix jours avec au minimum 15%
d'économies pour chacun d'entre vous sur
votre facture énergétique ça c'est
l'effet waouh
le deuxième exemple que je propose c'est
le traitement de la data vous savez que
si je compte l'énergie chez vous eh bien
je sais comment vous vous comportez dans
votre logement ou dans votre bâtiment
et ça ça une vraie valeur et cette
valeur à nous appartient elle est
purement territoriale et bien je vous
propose de la révéler de capitaliser de
décider en pleine conscience comment la
valoriser si nous réussissons à
travailler ses trois piliers dans la
société collaborative d'intérêt
collectif
eh bien nous avons mis en oeuvre les
conditions de coopération pour mettre
notre territoire nos organisations sur
une trajectoire durable et pérenne vers
le sens du bien commun et donc nous
serons sur la bonne trajectoire pour
rendre nos territoires et nos
organisations désirable dans la vie il y
a deux catégories d'individus ce qui
regarde le monde tel qu'il est et se
demande pourquoi ceux qui imaginent le
monde
il devrait être et se disent pourquoi
pas j'ai choisi mon camp
rejoignez moi
[Applaudissements]